hey lots of comm occurs we're here at
the Wizard World Chicago Comic Con this
is day one and we are so excited you go
see everything that's going on are you
excited Porter I'm very very always
excited about them what about you also
I'm so excited I'm turning green you're
excited too so we'll see you around the
con
in front of you now you see Jason Mewes
with the monkey exclusive footage for
awesome Kyle I said is Jason Mewes with
a monkey on him isn't that awesome
Jason boozing a monkey who would ever
thunk it even though I'm not really
surprised I don't know why Walter out
so we're on the secret escalator going
upstairs for the photo ops
I feel so exclusive up here it's like
behind the scenes
I heard of the tower of joy well this is
the tower of sorrow because nobody can
afford what's inside
it's not working
so come off
here with Chris for Clark what are you
painting today I'm doing a black widow
painting she's a character that I think
that a lot of people do paintings of a
lot of Marvel or superhero stuff is you
know like angry dudes fighting with you
know the Black Widow character something
almost like a like a vintage pinup sort
of thing but like more of a contemporary
sort of superhero twist on it and just
some intrigue with flames and everything
you know just kind of it makes a cool
story this little corner right here is
mine so I did that these are all
audience original oils that Captain
America Iron Man piece Thor down here
this spider-man venom and carnage piece
and
there's a cap and black panther and then
the Deadpool and Wolverine this was a
commission we did for somebody so this
was a fun piece it's not my concept it
was actually just an image from one of
the movie pictures coming out recently
but somebody saw it really loved it and
had me you know I added the shield I
added the tiara and did a couple things
different is there any place online we
could check you out yeah you can just
hashtag Christopher Clark art and you'll
find all my stuff great man okay so day
one of Wizard World Chicago 2016 is over
actually day two but it's Friday this is
the first day we came got some really
cool interviews with some really cool
people we saw some really cool stuff and
it's gonna be even better tomorrow
Ayanna and Heather will be here tomorrow
as well and we're gonna check out some
really cool stuff we have a little
surprise for you guys but there's some
some guys that are junkies of the screen
that you might know who they are that
we're gonna definitely get interviews
with tomorrow so make sure it's not the
same video so you know what let's just
cut to right now right yeah
say say flip the paint let the page
hey guys we're at Wizard World it's
Saturday it's the best day it's the
biggest day we're excited to do some
awesome things with the awesome comics
gang hi Anna
I like your cosplay today it's pretty
pretty awesome hey everybody it's Porter
here I got a special guest that I'm
interviewing today dr. Travis Langley
author of one of my favorite books
Batman and psychology it is a fantastic
book it's basically like a guide to
intro to psych but with superheroes for
a Suicide Squad you have the new Joker
Jared Leto's Joker and in your book you
classify the Joker in four stages of
like psychology and I was wondering what
stage would you classify Leto's Joker
we're seeing something different now
with the Joker I really think we're
seeing a bit big stage with the Joker
merge where in the comics you have him
doing things like cutting off his face
and the films you have him with tattoos
all over him
and I've always said the Joker defies
diagnosis we can talk about some of the
things he could have but it's not like
with the Riddler right he said here are
some definite obsessive-compulsive
qualities with the penguin here's some
definite histrionic qualities and we got
Psychopaths left and right with Batman's
rose galleries the Joker we don't know
what goes on inside his head we don't
know how crazy he is or what kind and
it's best that way the less we know
about him the less we know about his
background the better everybody out
there you guys should definitely pick up
this book it's an awesome intro to psych
it is incredibly enjoyable it reads like
a regular book but you're gonna have a
nice wide view of psychology after
reading it one of my favorite books ever
hey guys Ayanna here and I am here with
Jeana a comic book writer illustrator
and all-around amazing artist
we've talked a little bit about his
comic may before the first issue and
you've now got a couple issues out can
you tell me a little bit about the
series and how it got started I'm saying
this slightly jokingly because it's a
silly thing to say but it felt like the
universe was telling me I needed to
write my own book
so I finally just kind of hunkered down
and did the book I always want to do
which is May and now May is based on a
friend of yours cuz she's got caught all
these like really cool nerdy things
there's some really cool details in
there that I like she's based on a lot
of friends of mine um the thing is I
kind of feel like there's some there's
not a lot of representation of female
geeks and I felt like it was kind of a
world worth exploring um there's this
moment I hate inside of movies where you
he'll have a head in books this have
some books to where you'll have this
very geeky female character wears
glasses and then she whips off the
glasses and lets her hair down and
somebody says oh my god you're beautiful
I didn't realize you weren't ugly and
it's kinda like oh god I'm I'm never
gonna do that with maymay it's never
gonna take it may loses her glasses she
just can't see and I love that so much I
had someone who wears glasses I love
that and she's not gonna discover
herself by deciding that she's going to
be hanging out the cool kids and stop
doing geeky things she's going to do
what she loves doing all the time she
goes into this magical everything yeah
and I can guarantee you the way she
solves problems is not by being pretty
or by even turning to like her sisters
in Action Hero
her sister is just as straight out after
you can do flying kicks across the room
and that is never gonna be who may
become a of somebody who's going to
solve problems by being geek here and
geek here awesome that's great so you
could check out a lot of his work I have
found some special guest guys I don't
know if you guys recognize these people
but you should uh-huh and we're about to
go in to see the Back to the Future
panel which has Michael J Fox
Christopher Lloyd and Lea Thompson and
I'm very excited you guys excited what
it's gonna be heavy - okay well what's
gonna in there and check it out
everyone left us we're in line for back
to the future and everyone left us
Tamara's over there Walters over there I
Ana's over there
Jim's over there it's just us so I guess
this is our show now Porter
you didn't say anything apart like
officially advancing science fiction
movies someone has explained how it
works he doesn't
the funny thing about that character in
fact that you're to where I had to be
185 I'd remember Bob Saget it's like
you're playing gold but you can't play
slow some people like you have to be
fast
character
hey guys we're waiting outside for the
screen junkies panel it's been a long
day we're a little tired but we're still
super excited so let's go what was that
Oh
I'm here with Andy Dan and John from
screen junkies and we're gonna talk
first about honest trailers so how many
of you work on honest trailers here
fantastic so do all of you write it
together Spencer Gilbert and then our
man right here does the shore sure we do
I'm the boys well we know that you are
the voice but do you have any input on
the script as well improvise sometimes
they leave it in that you know and in
light smile again how do you guys decide
what movies to do for honest trailers a
lot of times if it's it's tied into
something that's coming out so if
there's a part of the new franchise
coming out there's a new Transformers
movie coming out we haven't done one of
those although we're running out of
those thankfully we'll do that or if
it's something that's tied into it
anniversaries via anniversaries the
shallows came out earlier this year so
we did jaws it's we wanted to have some
kind of tenuous connection to something
that's happening that week instead of
just like why are they doing that you
know evolution because because yeah that
was our most requested we asked fans
like a couple years ago what's your most
requested movie and they picked jack
ball so it wasn't us they pick Jagga
movies what's wrong with you people
um so at the end of the episode you say
something from the comments how do you
guys choose that as well I do I find
usually it's it's the most requested one
so if I see something with a lot of
thumbs up that'll do it if I see
something thats related to especially
when Game of Thrones is on a lot of the
quotes that have been on a recent
episode of TV show something stranger
saying something from something that's
popular and then I also look for just
foolishness like like voodoo biscuit dog
or whatever just weird things misspelled
misquoted stuff oh that's the best
look I am your father awesome well
something else that you guys do and that
we just saw was movie fights and you all
work on that as well how did that come
about we thought of that we basically
had some we had some YouTube time we'd
to fill so we were like listen we've
always wanted to try a podcast we had to
fulfill some hours for a YouTube thing
and then we were
wanted to do podcast and we always
wanted to do sort of this debate format
show that I've actually been playing
this version of them even as I was a kid
but I'd argue cartoon characters with my
whole family like Thanksgiving dinner
and so it just worked we're like what do
we try this and then Dan help we all
were like yeah that sounds fun we'd
built this idea of movie fights and then
did it on a lark and then ended up
taking off and people were watching for
an hour and a half like half a million
people we're starting to watch it which
is a big deal for YouTube and not
analytics and stuff so we suddenly were
like I guess we're gonna keep this thing
going that we were just doing for a
handful episodes and it really helped
blossom the channel into what it is
today because it put us out there I mean
Dan Merle is now a celebrity did you
know that was coming Dan no I had no
idea that any of that was gonna come on
I literally just like Andy's like we
need somebody to do this show this week
I'm like alright and the reason that I
did it so much is that no one else
wouldn't wanted to do it it was
something we were doing for fun but it's
great for conventions because now you
know we wouldn't move I'd started we
were not I mean you never thought we'd
get to do conventions and stuff and it's
such a fun thing to do live because you
can bring fans in you can have the
audience vote so it's a great
interactive thing I think when people
come here they're doing what they do at
home which is argue with us and decide
who they want to win which is a really
fun thing we love to do the Seljuk
Critic it's such a good fighter we have
to get you back on dog challenging you
come on out he weak actually came in
studio I did a really good round and he
came and he was here last he was
supposed to be here today but got sick
Shia LaBeouf thing last year that was a
low blow but you got to do it you got to
do to win well thanks a lot for chatting
with us today guys if you don't
subscribe to their Channel I don't know
what you're doing with your life
um but you should they're screen junkies
on YouTube subscribe watch this stuff
it's amazing okay that's the end of day
two that's Anna Saturday a big day hey
what's up man hey hi are we are we done
yet yes we are done you guys have fun
today yeah I am a lot of fun alright you
see some cool panels I'm so tired it was
so exciting you snap any next I did not
I'm gonna go you know can't incriminate
her okay how about you - I'm tired but
I'd finally got to interview Travis
Langley that was awesome you saw it was
great it's a lot of fun well we got the
last date tomorrow it's Sunday so until
then uh yeah we're gonna flip the page
right now because the same video ready
we'll start over here and we're gonna
flip the page ready 1 2 3 hey everybody
its Porter here we're at wizard world
day 3 we're a little bit tired but we're
ready to kick today's ass it's gonna be
awesome
I got some cool interviews coming up
gonna be some monkey business it's gonna
be some monkey business it's gonna be
fantastic I'm here with Fiona that's me
that's her convention time yeah and just
Walter so I'm you dressed up I'm already
cool so that's that's for sure All Right
see ya
man I really want to play some games but
it's like it's like super busy and
awesome comics who are you guys where's
Doug take a card
everybody here it's Porter from awesome
comics I've got Lucien here I wanted to
ask a couple of questions Lucien what
did you think what did you think of the
new Kong Skull Island trailer oh you
thought he's a little big for his
britches not really a too big of a cool
monkey oh you want your own movie oh he
wants his own movie okay now for the
flash season three we've got the flash
going to meet he's gonna fight whoa he's
gonna fight Gorilla Grodd what do you
think of that the flash is gonna get his
ass kicked I don't know about that he's
pretty quick Lucien here thinks Gorilla
Grodd is gonna beat the flash I can't
wait to see if he's right my little
buddy here is awesome thank you for the
interview thank you very much okay so we
we are in the line for daredevil it's an
hour before the actual panel and this
line is already longer than my entire
life it's gonna be a while wait with me
I've had a really different sort of
experience in that where I just really
don't know and then when I do sign up I
sign up for episodes but they don't tell
me which shows so I have no idea I'm
just sort of working and have this
question mark for the entire year or
just when are they gonna call me in for
what and how is it going to show up and
what I do
I commend pretty late so I will get
those first couple of episodes if that's
what happens on the second season when
it came on I didn't they didn't send me
any of the previous episodes so I
suddenly just came in the middle of all
this they're like you'll watch it at the
premiere like device well there was one
technology reconnaissance in the second
season we had a scene together we had
seen each other for a long time and when
when it was it took place in hospital
and Rosario Manta Claire temple has a
cut so it was like what is this
what's that and apparently had nothing
to do with our world but it's it's part
of Luke Cage so that the timeline had
been kind of thought through and worked
out so that whatever is going to
indicate which somehow at some point
during that show the death the next day
she's in hospital talking to me which I
just think they're really cool
Hey
I was just wondering since we've
advanced with ask questions all the time
you had a question with fans but would
it be where's the closest match the
amount of effort and time that it takes
to come to one of these and like be a
fan so yeah look where that commitment
comes from because we were trying to
think like who are like our people where
we could like spend the oh wait in line
before our it's incredible you guys to
do that we're trying to figure out less
I love you too bliss
my favorite my favorite
Oh toothless Oh to be a Dragon Rider
okay we're done that is all three days
of Wizard World
Chicago 2016 had a lot of fun met a lot
of cool cosplayers a couple of
celebrities and a couple screen junkies
so that was really fun
ah did you guys have a good time Porter
yes I did I had a fantastic time got to
interview some people Travis Langley
Lucian the Monkees my new little buddy
I love him to death fantastic it was a
lot of fun that monkey business never
anything like in my life have I seen
Hannah fun today I so much fun today
this whole weekend I got to paint a
bunch of figures today and like sit for
like half a second so like I really
liked that uh and then ya do some
shopping before we close up shop heck
yeah man we need some new shirts so
remember we're gonna be back probably a
c2e2 next year we're gonna be doing more
con coverage and I think we're gonna be
cosplaying as a Powerpuff Girls and
professor utonium blossom blossom
bubbles and head is gonna be Buttercup
and i'm gonna press utonium with the
chemical x vial if you want it demand it
demand it yes
do I do I don't I don't look good in
this one are you on the next pair John
can we ask you a favor
we end every episode with we'll see you
on the next page can we get the movie
honest trailer voice we'll see you on
the next page we'll see you on the next
page